[Music]
let's go to craig in indianapolis
indiana craig how can we help
hey ken john thanks for taking my call
just a little background 2005 we got
hooked up with the ranch ramsey baby
steps and
went through the process and we're now
in baby step seven and
uh baby steps millionaires way to go
nice
but
here's a couple months back i got
terminated from a job of 26 years
on a policy violation
and going forward i want to know how to
broach that subject in an interview
because i know the questions can be
asked how did you leave your last job ah
what was that
what are you comfortable sharing on this
policy violation i think it will help
it was
i was
i think it was misapplied but it was a
racial discrimination
and it was
it was definitely misapplied and but i
had no recourse in the end of the
right-to-work state so you can get fired
for any reason
so
when i
go to the next interview how do i when
they ask that question i want to be up
front
but how do i do that without
laying myself out
i will tell you that there are very few
questions
that truly stump me and and for the
moment i'm stumped in that this is such
a red flag for obvious reasons
certainly you understand uh you you
you do need to be up front
um
but you're but you know it sounds to me
like
okay so let me go back before i tell you
what i think you should say
you're telling me
that
um
it's your word versus their word they're
saying you violated something and you're
saying i did not do it
are you are you basically saying this
was a misunderstanding
no it wasn't a misunderstanding the
company got hit with a fairly
significant case a couple years back and
they are just hypersensitive to this
stuff
and it doesn't take and it literally
took almost nothing to trigger this
right but and i don't want you to share
what you said because i don't want to be
insensitive to anybody but was this
something you said or something you did
it was something that was posted
you posted something on your uh social
media
yeah it was
it was a group chat and i posted
something and
it
it was taken the wrong way
i didn't even
know imply it to be the way it was
one person took it and
their color okay let me ask you this if
you're in a job interview in the near
future
and uh would you feel comfortable
showing what you posted to anybody from
any walk of life absolutely you would
you would push it across the table
previous co-workers say what hap because
they're being real quiet about it
and i've had previous co-workers asking
well what happened we understand why
why you're gone so and i show them
they're like they shake their head they
just put in disbelief that i was
terminated over that
well then part of me says that you know
because if you start getting too gray
about this they're going to check your
references you have to assume that that
they're going to check your references
and so what you're doing
i mean even my supervisors and
everything will give me
the utmost
highly high recommendation okay wait a
second i know you're chomping at the bit
but but let me let me ask you this
if if you go interview for a company abc
all right and they call your past
company where you are terminated
you're telling me that the people who
terminated you are gonna say
great things about you and they're gonna
say manic
management tournament made me not my
direct supervisor
okay but my point is is that you're
going to have to plan for this so i
don't want to get cute i don't want to
try to describe
or coach you on some sort of dance i i
think you're gonna have to deal with
this so i think you're gonna have to
have your post and i'd print it out and
i would say here's what happened
and i've learned now here's the deal
i would show them the post
and then i would also say here's what
i've learned
even if you stand by what you posted
even if you think that you were wrongly
terminated or that you were
misunderstood or somebody was too
sensitive it doesn't matter i would go
here's what i posted
here it is here's who i am here's what i
learned and i would just own it and say
but for 26 years i had a stellar
performance and then i would just focus
on the positives why you want to be
there i just don't john am i missing
anything yeah here's the one thing craig
that's bothering me is
you're you have a very victim-centric
mentality
okay how so
well i i don't even know i just and even
if that you said it best kid even if
that's how it happened it comes across
as manipulative and disingenuous
and so i i love ken's idea
when you go for an interview you should
have a padfolio of some sort put it
print it off and put it in there and if
you get down that granular
then have the conversation and i love
what ken said
if you didn't learn something
from the exchange
if you didn't learn hey i hurt
somebody's feelings and i didn't even
mean to
i'm learning new things which by the way
i have done over the past 36 months
and i learn new things even if i think i
didn't mean to hurt it doesn't matter
what i meant the person on the other end
of what i said said hey that hurt please
don't do that and i can do one of two
things be an idiot and go almost sit or
i can say dude i don't want to hurt you
i'm sorry i'm gonna change that and so
you walking away saying what did you
learn i learned that um things that i
think are private on the internet are
public and so i'm gonna be more
responsible about what i post i'm gonna
have some friends that i reach out to if
i hurt their feelings and say hey did i
say this the right way or the wrong way
like right so
regardless of what happened
it's the well i don't know just
management man take some ownership
right i posted something i got fired for
it
i learned my lesson and i'm moving
forward i'm a good guy i got 26 years of
track record i have no
absolutely
nothing in my body wants to hurt other
people
and i did i crossed a line that my
company said i crossed the line i didn't
think i did but i did and i've learned
my lesson
like you see what i'm saying that is
ownership i'm taking this i'm sliding
across the table totally different
all shooks man i don't know you see what
i'm saying
yes yeah it's a hold your head up
handling it yeah so you see here's what
we're doing we're saying take the
elephant out of the room absolutely you
start acting like a politician you know
on the sunday morning shows they ask
them a direct question
is the sun hot and then they start going
well
it depends
on the position this guy talks about
rain all the time
i didn't ask you that so i would just
completely own it that way and uh john i
love the advice there's something to be
learned oh and i love that i love what
you said don't take on the role of
victim no because you're trying to
present yourself as a great candidate
and here's what they really care about
they're they only want to know one thing
and only one thing craig you ready can
craig help us win yep
and if they think that craig can help us
win they'll go you're hired this is a
guy that messed up and learned something
this is a guy that
that uh somebody messed him over and he
still learned something yeah that's the
guy i wanted my team
you're fine craig no shame in your game
head high
but take humility into the conversation
it's gonna be okay thank you for uh
trusting us with the call you're gonna
be okay